[Applause]
talk about awkward
that's demi lovato and boyfriend max
Eric watching Demi's old Disney movie
Camp Rock and yeah seems like it's Max's
first time seeing these flicks stupid
and immature some crazy lie [ __ ] but
not only did they watch the og movie
they also watched the sequel Hunger
Games
[Music]
until everyone else was just sleeping
felting our longbow and it's clear max
was not happy with the ending when team
camp Brock loses the big competition
[Laughter]
okay him and Demi are pretty darn cute
but let's go down memory lane just a
little bit more et was with Demi at the
premiere of Camp Rock in 2008 and just a
few years back we asked her if a Camp
Rock 3 would ever be possible after Joe
Jonas joked about making an r-rated
version if you like American Pie meets
Disney Channel
I love it if you guys for real discussed
it
yes we've really discussed oh my god
please meet can we say it right now to
ET it's gonna happen it's gonna happen
our rate of camera already
[Music]